all right just stopped recording my
outro time to give it into episode 2 of
a noob with the mill so start off with
one mill in this series and if we've got
some levels in the last episode up to
four point five mill Bank right now I'm
but to edit the last episode so I think
I'm gonna go by and do probably about
sixty attack on sand crab so let's go
ahead and do that and if we get a easy
clues I will do them alright so there we
go first
easy clue of the episode I decided I was
gonna go ahead and do the easy clue and
then finish off my 58 through 68 at
doing some medium clues so I'm gonna go
ahead and open it now and we get what
all right so just got a clue scroll
gonna go ahead and do that but before we
do gonna go to the GE and show you guys
would have been working on as far as
that goes alright so here we are and try
to ignore all the rune stuff I'm buying
that for another account none of the
money is being touched on this account
so it's all good but I bought 570
saradomin brew is for three point one
five mills will write that down chat
three one five seven I'm going to go
over here and decant all of them we
should be left with probably yeah one
two no sir whatever that's fine but I'm
gonna go ahead and buy one saradomin
brew now and see how much money we can't
expect to make alright so as you see
there seven nine eight seven so we're
gonna go ahead and sell all these for
that so so that means that I will be
able to make almost like 200 and what 60
70 K is that how much yeah so 260 270 k
profit off of that just a quick little
merch I'm doing so hopefully that works
out I'm just buying rude items for my
other account to do some Kurama just
store so it's not too big of a deal
alright so within doing to medium clue
steps we came back and all the saradomin
brew have sold if you guys won't know
how I find margins like this there is an
app that I use it's called GE tracker
they are sponsor of mine and they'll be
in the description down below go check
that out they have a ton of free and
paid to use tools this one I believe is
pay to use but they have a lot of
helpful tools so if you guys want to
check that out link is in the
description but let's get on into it I'm
gonna continue to buy more of these and
we will keep it going and there we go
here is another medium casket can't we
get anything this time we got a war
blessing that's something it's only
worth like not anything but it's
something 23 K we'll take it and some
whatever alright and there we go got the
EVAs cumulate err I want a afk range a
little bit so this was perfect I wanted
to get this first so there we go gonna
buy some Abbas key relators and get on
with some range levels also 21 Slayer
literally been sat here ready to record
for like five minutes now and I missed
the 50 range but there we go
I think I can just get by and now we're
blue d height plate body - which is kind
of weird since you need like the Dragon
Slayer wear green but yeah that's
whatever alright so I ended up using all
four thousand or maybe five I think it
was four thousand those field darts and
now I'm at fifty seven range almost 58
or at least a little over halfway
I do have an easy clue so we're gonna go
do that now and yeah I'm kind of
collecting caskets just because I think
it'd be cool but really no other reason
there we go so this is from yesterday's
surprises may have changed a lot however
I was able to buy all these saradomin
breeze for pretty much 3.4 mm I'm gonna
see how much I can sell them all for now
alright so there we go went ahead and
bought one for 7.6 I don't know if I'll
be making that much money off of this
but that's fine so go ahead and put it
up for seven five nine four and we're
going to drop it by one that's how much
money I made so I'm at three point four
one seven mil and I barely made any
money off of that I made about 20k which
sucks but uh you know that's what
happens and the prices change like that
alright so just got done buying some
more death runes as you can see here I
ended up getting like what eight nine
thousand I think it was so I started off
with three point five mil and now with
the coins and the deference I'm up to
over for almost four point one so to get
six under K profit that we made I ended
up hitting my log in timer and there's a
lot of fold world so I decided I'd stop
with it for a little bit and we're gonna
sell these difference alright so here we
go going to go ahead and get sixty range
after this I'm going to go ahead and get
sixty attack and then we will go ahead
and do the monkey madness quests that
I've been waiting to do I was gonna do
monkey madness quest first but that was
like
and doesn't sound like too much fun so
here I am gonna pot up and yeah good
about here in a second but in the
morning we will get the level I'm not
gonna miss it I'm not alright there we
go 60 attack I'm sorry I'm moving the
mic but there we go so done being a plug
here with the rune skin gonna go get a
dscam and I think that's going to be the
end of my sand crab adventure it's
really nice to FK but nightmares I want
to eventually be better and I got to do
some Slayer because I'm only 21 and I
love Slayer alright so I haven't been
playing a whole lot today however
whenever I was on I managed to go ahead
and throw in an offer for these super
combat potions so as you can see about
500 Ted one dose for 1.86 mil and I'm
gonna see how much I can sell them on
for I don't think I'll make a whole lot
here but I think I'll make a little bit
and that is better than nothing with all
the cash that I had I figured I'd put it
towards something all right pretty much
1.9 mill on the dot is what we were able
to get off of that I don't know what I
ended up buying them for so I don't know
how much we made or so we ended up
making 40k that's ridiculous
the price of super combats went down a
lot which is why I didn't make any money
off of them but I'm not too upset about
it it's a little bit of profit so we'll
take it and there we go so we got some
attack XP probably should have done this
earlier if I would have known I got that
much XP but yeah to quest points gonna
go on and do the Grange free quest now
and there we go got 20 agility I also
think I'll go to the bank real quick but
I think it's Olaf yeah - - party hat
inspects so far so I'm almost done with
those and I'll go and find another merch
but for the time being I think I'm gonna
go ahead and just get 30 agilities just
so I can knock out to do the Alka rig
agility course and then we'll move on to
the quest alright so there we go that is
25 chili D I realized that I [__] hate
this and I'm just gonna finish this lap
and then go to the quiz I'm not getting
30 [__] that alright so as far as the
success of the party at specs merch as
you guys can see how 4.1 almost mil
right here and I initially invested 3.7
so that was a good 300 k profit so I'm
gonna go ahead and probably merge them
again since I feel like they would be
pretty decent right now so I bought all
the party hats back so bought them all
for 3.8 minute Rai to sell them on for
about what I sold those for which should
be about a hundred k profit off of each
one hopefully we'll see how they do
alright so here we go this should be the
end of the grand jury quest which is
pretty cool I saw them able actually to
get some agility
here which is nice I didn't I didn't
know that that's probably get the ending
get 30 mi on that so there we go so I
should get an attack level as I did up
to 62 and agilities actually up to
almost 32 which is pretty sick so there
we go
last quest before we get the Dragon Skin
let's go there we go I actually saw the
price before I end up putting these in
like this suggested price so I put it a
little bit below that and we turned the
3.8 millimole 4 into 4 point 2 so that's
a get a 400 K profit I'm gonna go ahead
and try and buy those for the same price
I don't know if I will get them but I'm
gonna go ahead and try so I'm gonna
throw out an offer and yeah I'll try to
buy 3 more alright so try to make this
easy as possible to figure out since I
have a lot of slots as you guys can see
basically I ended up merging some
shamrock pages as you can see two point
eight mil for that so I had four point
eight mill in vested into these gonna
collect all this so that's four mill and
then on top of that we have nine under K
here and 638 K there so in total I think
I made about seven which is pretty
insane so I mean there was some really
good margins on them and I found it
without even having to buy the pages
himself to find the margin so I did make
a lot of money off of them was pretty
lucky but uh yeah great so here we go
this should be the end of the easy clue
scroll I know I keep saying I'm gonna do
monkey madness but I'm actually going to
do it after this so let's go ahead and
clap I believe this dude just chillin
right here but uh you know I'm gonna do
my thing let's find it and there we go
so monkey man has completed that is huge
get to use the d skim now probably start
doing some slayer and chillin but I
think I also have some combat reward so
I can go up here and get so we'll see
about that
boom 61 strength and 63 attack and 44
defense Jesus okay didn't know that's
how that worked but there we go got some
levels let's go
being on a noob account this is an
utterly terrifying scene if you just
look around like what someone just
[__] was on a rampage alright so I
went ahead and put my D skin to use and
start killing some dragons I was trying
to get a hard clue scroll so that I
could have something to like work
towards because I don't really know what
quest to do I'll probably just keep
following the most efficient quest order
guide or like
but I was hoping I get a hard clue in
that give me someone work for but didn't
get anything kind of want to go quest so
I'm gonna do some now we have some
failed mergers going on well not really
failed these these jars of sand aren't
even buying but the dragon darts I
actually might lose like 150 K on cuz a
second merchant all right so the fishing
contest quest is about to be done right
now that was really quick honestly so
it's pretty nice we got that one done I
think I'm gonna go do Tower of life now
I believe all right so I wanted to go
start the quest realized that I I need
ten construction and I only have one so
I bought 300 planks and 300 nails we're
gonna see how far I can get with
construction before that I'd rather like
just go as far as I can just not just
only get ten so we'll see what we can do
boom would you look at that just start
to something new there we go look at
this house it's like it's all my own I
feel so alone here
alright so gonna go ahead and finish off
the construction now I didn't use all my
planks but I feel like this is a good
point and so we got the ten construction
that we needed to fit into the quest and
a little bit decided I'd you know get a
decent amount of level so we're almost
850 total forty construction that's
pretty good progress I'm happy with it
alright so here we go this should be the
Tower of Life done let's do it and there
it is get some XP I think it'll give us
a thieving level actually I think two
thieving levels so there we go
gonna go on and do breast list now I
don't know what I needed to do I think I
need to do shield over Rob next but I
mean think that is I have to find
someone I don't know how to find anyone
for that and there we go showed him the
certificate and one quest point done so
another quest done and yeah shout out to
him for you know hitting me up with the
half certificate and then someone else
in the clan chat there we go isn't him
right there he noticed me so what little
side note ended up selling off all the
dragon darts probably made about 80 GP
off of all of them are off of each one I
guess so I made a hundred 20k off that
merge so that's pretty good gonna go
ahead and find something else since
nothing seems to really be buying at all
got some wood cutting but other than
that really Oh actually we got a level
which is pretty cool and gonna move on
from there now alright so there we go
this is the end of Demon Slayer not too
shabby
I actually got lucky when I had to when
I had to go and say the things at the
end cuz two of them started with CA and
that's
I wrote down so I was screwed but I got
lucky on that one all right so this
should be the end of rag-and-bone man
let's go ahead and check it out so there
we go
all right I don't think we get any
levels out that oh yeah all right so
here we are going to go ahead and finish
up Black Knights fortress another three
quest points that brings us up to 67 I
think now I'm gonna go do Lost City and
then that'll be it for the questing for
a little bit I kind of want to go on a
Slayer grind and I know eventually I'm
gonna have to do lost city for child or
whatever so all right and here we are
going to finish off of the lost city
quest so there we go
and there we go all right so there we go
first assignment and trolls you have 65
that's not bad trolls aren't trills
aren't terrible we can do that alright
so there we go ended up getting 28
slayer off that test pretty cool we also
got a strength level which is pretty
nice so we ended up getting I think six
or seven slayer levels along with one
strength and a little over halfway
towards 63 which is good eventually once
I get 65 and 65 then I'll go and get
myself a dragon defender but until that
time we're gonna go get another task
alright so there we go another test done
under this test we got up to 30 slayer
almost 31 and there's 63 strengths that
wasn't even playing that's [__]
hilarious but let's go ahead and get our
next answer here we go so get another
test from jelled or however you say 123
pyro fiends or whatever I got I don't
have to say anything but uh not too
shabby I do have a merge going on in the
GE right now so we're gonna go ahead and
check that out
this is gonna be step forward this
should be the very end so let's go ahead
and get our casket and alright so there
we go I've got some black message sell
off this was a merchant I did while I
was on my Slayer task so I bought them
all for a 404 ml 890 K everything as you
guys can see I was able to make about a
hundred ATK off of them in total so my
initial plan was actually uncharged them
however by the time I got done with my
task there was more of a margin to just
sell them back on than to actually
uncharged them so we made a decent
amount of money doing that alright so
here we go another test have another
merge done with black mess and also got
a medium close
so we will be doing that however we have
to get this task and I can never find
where she's at but there we go so 113
god damn banshees [__] that god they're
terrible and here we are so here we are
with the merch is so bought some black
mats for 100 or 811 K and as you guys
can see I you know the Martins succeed
69k know the margins 59 K there we go so
I'm gonna go ahead and sell these all
off for 870 K minus one cuz i undercut
cuz I'm a little [__]
but those are all label sell those 5.2
so I'm gonna make about 350 K off that
which isn't too bad at all alright
reached a little bit of an impasse here
I have to do I have to be able to get on
miscellanea do this medium clue so I
think we're gonna do four Romanick
trials now I probably need to do some
stuff work though alright so before I do
that quest death runes are really high
right now they're about 314 GP per so
you're gonna go and just buy a ton of
them while I watch a Tottenham and
Chelsea game so let's go ahead and do
that yeah it didn't work out the way I
expect I expected it to go in during
peak hours it's like three o'clock my
time so it's pretty it's pretty peak
hours it's only able to get like 2.3 K
and I mean all the worlds have like 200
or like 300 stock whenever I get there
so it's not really worth doing now I'll
probably pick this back up later in the
black mass as you guys can see well I
guess you guys can't really see right
now I'm only gonna end up making about
30k off each one because the price is
kind of dropped on them so we're making
a little bit but not as much as we
thought we were going to so I've
actually had some decent merch as you
guys can see I was able to buy a hundred
sixty dragon darts for 370 K and then I
went ahead and sold all of them on for
pretty much 100k profit they have huge
margins right now and I'm gonna go ahead
and recheck what their margins are but I
also was able to flip the rest of my
black mass obviously and I flip some
death runes for probably about a good I
don't know
80 to 90 K profit which is pretty nice
this is just gonna go enough preface
what I'm doing right now so dragon darts
GS could see had insane like margins
right now like I could insta sell them
right now if I made them in darts for
220 profit per one which means once all
these are done that'll be a good 440 K I
could wait for them to sell on for this
price but I don't think they will so I
in Cebu
mm dragon dart tips and someone in the
oh seven hopers clan chat is currently
going to help me out and make this for
me his name I think was bone so uh yeah
I'm gonna go and have him make these for
me so alright so the profits apparently
will continue I will now go ahead and
sell these on for 263 and that will make
us a good fair bit of money so we were
able to sell off almost all of them
there we go we were able to sell off all
of them which is really good so as you
can see there five point almost four mil
and I bought them all for ya we ended up
making about 500k off of that so that
was quite good and I am very impressed
with that
alright so there we go v test done JH
got 35 Slayer we didn't get a strength
level however we're closed apparently on
your fifth test that's when you start
getting a point so that's pretty cool
well uh we'll work up towards the Slayer
home quickly I'm sure alright so next
task here we go give me an assignment
police and there we go 117 troll it's
actually really good XP and I'm able to
actually stay a lot longer than I
thought so I don't mind this task too
bad at all there we go so another task
done gonna go ahead and get my next task
almost sixty five strength and almost
thirty nine Slayer so we got pretty
close and let me go see what we can get
now alright here we go so assignment and
and rock slugs Jesus Christ don't want
to kill myself update I have a lot of
super attack potions I guess it's a
short way to say it I I bought them all
I don't know as you guys can see here I
bought 750 of them for 690 coins the
other thousand that I bought was for I
believe like 480 which is insane I think
that they were being dumped because of
people training air blower for raid so
I'm going to go ahead and see what
attack potion that's worth right now
alright so as I buy one you can see I
cannot even buy one for 5% over which
means and here we are about to get 65
strength I just wanted to let you guys
know that I absolutely hate rock slugs
and hope I never get this task again
there we go another task wrapped up and
I'm a man account right now I just found
out the death runes they're worth 380 GP
each and it is 2 a.m. where I'm at so
I'm hoping I can find some empty world
so let's go get a task and then
hopefully I can get some deference
alright and here we go so next task
cockatrice is that's actually pretty
good considering we you know have never
had this task and it's pretty decent XP
from what I remember at least compared
to what I've been doing alright so we do
have something to do first though
according GE tracker I can't sell on a
malediction board for three point three
mil and as you guys can see here I
practically spent about two point nine
to actually buy all the parts for this
malediction Ward's so pretty hyped about
that I know I did buy a lot of extra
shards obviously but that's just so that
I can buy these whenever and I'll always
have these ago because this is really
the one that you actually you know could
that would actually change in price
these two were that's like 50k and
that's like 200 so they're pretty low
and relatively low risk guess who forgot
their [__] knife god damn and I gotta
hop around world's and just pray that
someone opens this you didn't need any
requirements for this but now I see a
smithing sign up here which kind of
terrifies me so please for the love of
God hey there we go okay nice I thought
I was gonna need a smithing level was
pretty terrified but there we go that's
a good probably about 350 400 K profit
right there I'll be doing that a lot
throughout the series whenever there are
margins on it so expect that every now
and then for a
little bit of a GP booze alright so
there we go finish up my death runes so
I came here with about 1.1 milind yeah
we're gonna go see what we can sell all
of these on for alright so I bought the
death room for 367 which is a huge
margin honestly so there we go
I turned 1.1 milind at 1.6 also some I
didn't say margin that I just hit my mic
but and in same margin that I found was
malediction shards too so they're around
200k you can sell them sometimes for up
to 350 but right now I've bought three
for 25k if that isn't insane I do not
know what is alright so I want ahead and
bought some death rune there we go
finish off my pin but as you guys can
see I have nine point three thousand
down here they are extremely expensive
right now however that means the worlds
are pretty packed for buying them so as
you guys can see 359 apparently is what
I can sell them on for there we go 359
the amount of money that I actually
spent getting these was 2.5 mill so I
went ahead and made 800 + UK on that so
I'm pretty happy with it
also in case you were wondering I did
sell off all these super attacks and yet
death runes are almost done so I went
ahead and made up a malediction Ward so
as you guys can see I bought this for
2.7 but I also had to probably spend
about a hundred K on the other two
pieces since I was able to get the
malediction shards - for insanely cheap
and yeah so there we go made about what
400 K ish yeah 420 K or so so that is
lit means all right so apparently right
now o diem wards are 4 mil pretty much
on the dot and I was able to spend what
do we have here 300 K in that one
another hundred cane that once a 4-under
K there so three point five mil
to go ahead and get this so I'm gonna
make 500 K and that only took like two
minutes to buy those pieces I got pretty
lucky with that I think alright so I
went ahead and insta sold it for 4 mil
and 10k you might be wondering why did
you insist L it because I don't have
enough money right now to constantly put
in more offers for these things so it is
more beneficial to me right now to be
able to have this offer in right away
than to actually just wait it out so
that's that's why and here we go another
odeon
ward selling off gonna go ahead and
hopefully hope it sells for something
around there there we go
so another 500k mate and feeling good
alright so there we go another two more
odium Ward's made I made a 500k off of
both of these so another mill in total
which is really nice and yeah oh diem
shard three prices have really shot up
so I can't really do that anymore
however you know I'll just wait it out
eventually they'll drop again and there
we go both odium or two have sold on so
I'm gonna go ahead and I think this is
where we're gonna end off this video so
I will save from Nik trials for next
video however we're gonna do a quick
price check of a bank before it ends so
go ahead and bank everything and boom
thirteen point seven mils so we're
definitely on the come-up
I think last episode we ended off with
about five mil this episode we're going
out with about fourteen which is really
nice next episode maybe more progress
type stuff than money making cuz right
now I don't need 14 mil with the stats
that I have it's practically useless but
uh yeah hope you guys enjoyed the video
if you guys did make sure to leave a
like if you guys have anything you want
to say to me and you can either message
me in-game join our 7 helpers or comment
down below if you guys want see future
videos soon as they go live make sure
hit that sub button also check out the
Twitter in the description but
nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day and least and I made that
outro really fast I would side plate